I want to take up in Volume 12, October the 3rd, 1918.
How justice must balance itself.
Louisa said she was praying that Jesus would placate himself, and he came for a little,
and she said to him, "My love, Jesus, how awful it is to live in these times.
Everywhere one hears of tears and sees pains.
My heart bleeds, and if your holy will did not sustain me, I certainly would not be able
to live any longer, but how much sweeter would death be for me.
So this longing to leave this earth and be with the Lord, you will find also in 2 Corinthians
chapter 5, verses 6 to 10.
Jesus said, "My daughter, it is my justice that must balance itself.
Everything is balanced in me."
So you'll notice that the Lord is telling us that when we go to extremes, we're out
of balance, and therefore whatever the extreme is cannot be correct.
The church has always told us that virtus in Mediostat virtue walks the middle road.
In other words, there's no extreme on either side.
So Jesus said, "Everything is balanced in me."
However, the scourge of death touches souls with the imprint of grace.
In other words, even though what is happening all around us is in fact a chastisement at
the same time, it is grace, it is the Lord putting a correction into the system and trying
to get human beings to bow their proud heads, that's Isaiah chapter 2, verses 7, 9, 11,
that we must bow our proud heads and acknowledge him and go into right relationship with God.
We meaning the human race, not any particular individual.
However, the scourge of death touches souls with the imprint of grace, so much so that
almost all of them ask for the last sacraments.
Now, we are in 1918, and as I'm reading this in 2020, there's no guarantee that any of
them would ask for the last sacraments, that's how much we have deteriorated.
Man has reached such an extent that only when he sees his own flesh being touched and feels
himself being undone does he shake himself, so much so that others who are not being
touched live lightheartedly and continue their life of sin.
I want to give you two very important texts for that.
One is Job chapter 2, verses 4 to 7.
And there you will find a dialogue between Satan and Jesus, in which the enemy says to
Jesus that no wonder Job has been faithful because you haven't touched his flesh, but
touch his flesh and it will curse you to death.
It's very interesting.
Satan seems to know us rather well.
The other one is Revelation 9 from verses 20 to 21, in which we're told that in the
last days, people not experiencing the chastisement in their own particular area will carry on
as if nothing was going on.
We're living through that stage, unfortunately.
So Jesus says it's necessary then for death to harvest in order to remove many lives which
do nothing other than make a thorns sprout beneath their steps.
And this is so in all classes, both in the laity and in the religious, in other words
in the clergy and in the laity.
So I want to give you a Revelation 11, 18.
I will destroy the destroyers of the earth.
Okay.
And I want to give you a Revelation 9 from verse 15 to 18.
"And my daughter, these are times of patience," he said, "do not become alarmed and pray
that everything may abound to my glory and for the good of all.
So I want to give you Isaiah 28, verses 14 to 19, and verse 22.
Now, don't forget that in 1918 there was the terrible Spanish flu.
And it killed more than 20 million people as far as I know, including the two little
children of Fatima."
So let's come to October 14, 1918.
True peace comes only from God.
And the greatest chastisement of all are not the natural disasters but the triumph of evil.
So don't forget there was the communist revolution, the Bolshevik revolution in 1917.
There was two waves of it.
One was in March 1917 and the other was October 1917.
And the entire royal family in Russia were murdered in July the 18th, 1918.
So the triumph of evil were at the time, you're obviously looking at the triumph of communism
in the world because communism is Satan's own method of destroying all faith in people.
So Jesus said to Louisa, "My daughter, governments feel the ground missing under their feet.
In other words, the leaders don't know what to do.
I will use all means to make them surrender."
That's very interesting because that means that the Lord is completely determined to get through.
And I will use all means to make them surrender and to make them come back to their senses.
Now Isaiah 9, 6, we'll tell you what's wrong.
They're blind, they're deaf, they're dumb, their hearts are hardened from sin.
In Luke 15, 17, the boy only came back to his senses once he had got really, really hungry.
So that's the parable of the prodigal son.
And I want to give you Amos 4 verses 1 to 12.
That's one of the reasons why the Lord allows famine and illness to come to us.
We have to come back to our senses.
It is to make them come back to their senses and to make them know that only from me can
they hope for true peace.
Now I won't give you all the references, but you can at least look up one yourself that
on the night that Jesus was born, the angel is declared that he was the prince of peace
or the author of peace.
So that's in Luke chapter 2.
And only God can give us lasting peace.
Now the arrangements that governments make between each other to try and stop killing
each other is not real peace.
Peace is a completely different reality altogether.
Peace is something that is established in your own being, in your union with God.
And it's established between you and your neighbor, in your union with your neighbor.
And it's established between you and the entire universe in your proper union with the earth
and the world that God has given to us.
So Jesus said, "I humiliate one and then another, and I make them become friends and
then enemies."
These are the governments, they don't understand what's actually going on.
The whole thing is being unseated.
So I want to give you Isaiah 30 verse 1 for that.
I will do all sorts of things to make them surrender.
Now it's a dreadful thing if the Lord has to force us to surrender.
The great gift that God has asked us is for us to surrender our will to his divine will.
That's the big thing, but he knows that we're very, very reluctant to do that.
The people who say they've done it can be very reluctant in certain areas.
We don't give everything to him.
So I will do all sorts of things Jesus said to make them surrender.
I will make their arms fall off.
Now that doesn't literally mean their physical arms, but the arms in the scriptural sense
means power, their strength.
So if you just take the word arm there and write the word strength or power.
I will do things unexpected and unforeseen in order to confound them.
Well that's exactly what you read in Isaiah 29 verses 13 to 14.
So they cannot say, "I know all this."
That's the problem that people have known Christianity for so long.
They can say, "You can't give me a homily, I don't know, I know it all."
But if they know it all, they are responsible before God.
So I will do things unexpected and unforeseen in order to confound them and to make them
understand the instability of human beings and of themselves.
Well, there's nothing like the pandemic that we have now for making everybody feel uncomfortable
and insecure and making us feel just how fragile we are.
And that's one of the lessons of a chastisement is to make them understand that God alone is
the stable being from whom they can hope for every good.
And if they want justice and peace, they must come to the fount of true justice and true
peace only God can give it to us.
Otherwise they will achieve nothing and they will continue to struggle.
And if it seems that they will combine, it won't be lasting and the brawls will start
again even worse.
So I want to give you Isaiah chapter 30 verse 15.
If you read the Old Testament, you'll realize this has been happening forever with human
beings.
The Old Testament is full of this.
Jesus said, "My daughter, the way things are, only my omnipotent finger can fix them."
In other words, this is 1918.
That's a century ago that things are so bad that only God could fix them.
And at the appropriate time, He said, "I'll do it," so that's Isaiah 30 verses 19-26,
where you are told that once you have had the water of distress and the bread of suffering
to get on with, then you'll allow God to bring this solution.
But in the meantime, great trials are needed and will take place in the world.
Now if God says that, it will happen.
If one of us says it, then we're like the weather veins, we come and we go.
Therefore He said, "It takes great patience on Louis' part to put up with all of this."
When He added with the more moving and sorrowful tone, "My daughter, the greatest chastisement
is the triumph of evil."
For that, I want to give you Ezekiel 10, 18-22, and Ezekiel 11-22-23, that when Israel
sinned enough, the Lord actually left the temple, and He didn't come back until they
repented.
We are in grave danger of that situation now.
So He said, "The greatest chastisement is the triumph of evil, because nothing unholy
or unworthy can enter the presence of God."
So that's your Hebrews 12-14.
And if we are to enter the presence of God, then purification is really necessary.
There's no way out of that.
More purges are needed, Jesus said, and the evil ones in their triumph will purge the
church.
Now, the evil ones in their triumph is the persecution of the church from the Communists
and the Freemasons.
You've done terrible damage to the church.
Just look at what happened to the Orthodox church in Russia and its satellites and the
millions of martyrs that came out of it.
I will purge my church.
And so when the power of communism fell, the first thing the people did was to put the
cross back on the churches.
In other words, we need God.
So more purges are needed, and the evil ones in their triumph will purge the church.
And then I will crush them—that is the most wonderful news—that in the end, communism
will be defeated, but only by God himself.
And I will scatter them like dust to the wind.
I want to give you Isaiah 33-1, and just remind you that the Old Testament empires were allowed
by God to punish Israel, God's people, when they sinned.
But then if you read the prophets, you'll find that these empires were punished for
the stuff that they did, because all human beings are responsible.
So I want to give you Isaiah 31-6 as well.
And of course, Revelation 11-18, that the evil ones will be removed.
So then I will crush them, and I will scatter them like dust in the wind.
Now to scatter something like dust in the wind means that it is useless.
It can't be recovered.
It has no good in it, so you just simply get rid of it.
It's waste.
Therefore, do not be troubled at the triumphs you hear.
This means all the arrangements that have been made after the First World War, and some
areas appear to triumph.
For example, it appeared that Germany was completely defeated.
Then you have to come to the Second World War, and Germany had to be defeated again.
But Germany is now ruling Europe.
Things are not what they seem, not at all.
So don't be troubled at the triumphs you hear, but cry with me over their sad lot.
Now their sad lot is the condition of their souls, and that is the thing that is important,
because that is the thing that's going to last forever.
Unless we intercede, unless we do penance.
So October the 16th, 1918, Jesus predicts wars.
The Second World War is just about to finish, and he's predicting more.
So this is Louisa, the prophet, and so it's Amos 3, 7.
And I want to give you Isaiah 34 verses 1 to 6 as well.
Louisa said she was feeling very afflicted because of the privation of her beloved Jesus,
and her mind was made gloomy by the thought that everything in her had been either the
crafting or fantasy of the enemy, now she gets that problem frequently.
Rumors circulate of peace and triumph for Italy.
Now remember what Jesus has just said in the last message.
Do not be troubled at the triumphs you hear, but cry over their condition.
So rumors circulate of triumph for Italy, while I remember that my sweet Jesus had told me
that Italy would be humiliated.
What pain, what mortal agony to think that my life was a continuous deception.
I felt that Jesus wanted to speak to me, but I didn't want to hear him.
I rejected him.
In other words, Louisa actually has an amazing love for her country.
And if her country is going to really suffer, she doesn't want to hear anymore.
And so she gives resistance to Jesus.
The reason why I'm underlining this is the level of her relationship with God is so high
that it should comfort you if you have moments of resistance.
If I have moments of resistance, I just say to him, "Hold on to me until I come round.
This is not my final position.
This is just the emotional state.
Hold on to me.
I still am completely committed to your will."
So she was completely committed to his will, and yet there was this emotional resistance
inside of her.
I fought for three days with Jesus, she said, and many times I was so exhausted I didn't
have the strength to reject him.
And then Jesus would speak and speak, and I, drawing strength from his words, would say
to him, "I don't want to know anything."
Finally, Jesus surrounded her neck with his arm, which of course is Song of Songs, chapter
2, verse 3.
SS, 2, 3, his left hand under my head, and his right arm embracing me.
Cam yourself, he said, "It is I."
It's really fantastic that statement, "Aego, Amy, E-G-O, E-I-M-I."
That's exactly what Jesus said to the apostles in the middle of the storm when he walked to
them on the waters, "Aego, Amy, it is I."
And therefore he's revealing his divinity at this moment.
"Listen to me," he said, "Don't you remember that months ago as you were lamenting to me
for poor Italy, I said to you, my daughter, those who win lose and those who lose win."
Okay?
Because that's a message that was given earlier.
Italy, France, have already been humiliated because he had just said, "Some will go down
and some will appear to conquer."
Italy and France have already been humiliated and will no longer be the great powers that
they used to be until they are purged and they have returned to me free, independent
and peaceful.
Now this is a century later and I just asked the question, "Are they purged?
Are they free, independent and peaceful?"
Now politically you would say, "Yes," spiritually question mark.
In the triumph, Jesus said, "Which is merely apparent, which they enjoy, they already suffer
the greatest of humiliations, not themselves, but a foreigner, not even a European, came
to drive the enemy away."
There's the American forces that Jesus is talking about.
So if this could be called a triumph, which it isn't, it is the triumph of the foreigners,
the USA people, but this is nothing.
Now more than ever, they will lose more in moral things as much as in temporal because
this will make them dispose themselves to committing greater crimes, to fierce internal
revolutions, such as to surpass even the tragedy of the war.
Now the way God sees things and the way human beings see things are very, very different.
So that's Isaiah 55, mmm, 54, oh sorry, I get that one right now.
I'll give you the words and you can look it up yourself.
My thoughts are not your thoughts.
My ways are not your ways.
In fact, my thoughts and my ways are as different to yours as the heavens are from the earth.
I think it's not Isaiah 55, but anyway, whichever one it is, it's verses 8 to 10.
So it might be 48 or something like that.
So the Lord is showing that the way he sees things is completely different to the way
that human beings look at things.
And besides Jesus said, what I told you did not regard only the present times, but also
the future.
That's why I pointed out like has this happened fully.
It is normal in prophecy that there are different stages of fulfillment before the final fulfillment.
So what I told you doesn't just regard the present, but also the future.
And what will not happen now will happen then.
Very interesting.
And if anyone will raise difficulties or doubts, it means that he knows little or nothing about
the way I speak.
In other words, that a prophetic announcement has different stages of fulfillment.
We see this in the Bible very, very clearly, that it's only when you come to the book
of Revelation that you see how all the prophecies of the Bible and all the great symbols that
the Bible used all come to their final conclusion there.
But there was different levels of fulfillment along the way.
And not all of the prophecies, of course, have been fulfilled because the final, final,
final end times has not come.
We're in end times, but not the final, final ones.
So Jesus said, "My words are eternal just like me."
That's Matthew 24, 35.
So when he says something, that's it.
That's the reality.
He's not saying it for the sake of it.
Human beings can say things hoping that what they're saying might happen or might not happen.
But that's not the same with the Lord, what he says is.
So to soften the blow for Louisa, Jesus said, "I want to tell you something, consoling."
Italy, France, now win, and Germany loses.
All nations have some black stains, and all of them deserve humiliations and crushings.
So there Jesus is talking about national sins as distinct from individual sins.
All of them deserve humiliations and crushings.
There will be a general uproar.
There will be confusion everywhere.
By the sword, which means war, by fire.
We've had an extraordinary manifestation of fire in the past century and in recent times.
By water, tsunamis, by sudden deaths, by contagious diseases, which were right in the
middle of one right now.
He said, "That's the way I will renew the world."
Now renew the world means actually getting human beings to turn away from sin and death
and selfishness and hell and to turn to God and grace and holiness and heaven.
That's the renewing of the world.
He said, "I will make all things new."
I will make new things.
The nations will form a sort of tower of Babel.
Now that has actually happened in Europe.
Government building in Brussels is actually built on the model of a painting of the tower
of Babel.
And they claim that we've managed to put all languages together.
We've conquered this business, that they were all scattered because of language at
the tower of Babel, we think that we've solved that.
Very foolish.
And also we've formed a tower of Babel with our technology.
We think we've actually managed everything, including how to create, how to make completely
new things.
So the whole technology of robots and all of that kind of stuff, a man thinks he's got
the creator.
He said, "The nations will form a sort of tower of Babel and they will reach the point
of being unable even to understand one another," which is very interesting.
So how the Lord's going to bring that about, I don't know.
The peoples will rebel among themselves.
Now all over the world today you have social unrest.
You can see it on your television screens.
They will no longer want kings, that means political leaders.
And you see that all over the world today, they're throwing out their political leaders.
All will be humiliated and peace will come only from me.
So Jesus keeps repeating this to make sure we somehow get the message.
And if you hear them say peace, it won't be real peace, it's only apparent because what
human beings do is not peace is just that they make good truth.
Once I have purged everything, I will place my finger in a surprising way.
Now this is twice, we've just read, that Jesus would place his finger on something.
Now if you take your right hand and press down the three fingers and put your thumb
over and raise up your first finger and lift it up, that's the symbol of God's power,
the finger of God's right hand, okay.
Sam 8, for example, tells the Lord, "You made everything with your fingers."
In other words, it is absolutely nothing to you to do this.
So I will place my finger, he says.
In a surprising way, and I will give true peace as the real solution, then all those
who are humiliated will return to me.
This is the most wonderful, wonderful prophecy, okay.
Germany will be catholic, can you imagine?
I have great designs upon her, England and Russia, and every place where blood was shed
will rise again to faith and will be incorporated into my church.
In other words, the very place where communism had won its greatest victory, which is in
Russia, will return to the Lord.
There's the triumph of good, there's the triumph of the two hearts of Jesus and Mary.
So England and Russia and every place where blood was shed will rise again to faith and
will be incorporated into my church.
There will be the great triumph of the union of peoples.
In other words, what the one world government is trying to do through its own ungodly ways,
only the Lord can actually bring about the union of the human race and the unification
of the church as well.
Therefore pray, he said, it takes patience because this will not happen so soon, but
it will take time.
So there's going to be a new era of peace, there's going to be a new era of one fold
and one shepherd, there's going to be the new era of the kingdom of God on earth as it
is in heaven.
There's going to be the new Jerusalem.
What Jesus has done there is brought an enormous number of prophecies from the Bible and from
modern times, he's brought them all together and he's just sort of named things.
It's very unusual that he does that and it's absolutely fantastic.
But when you're in the middle of a chastisement as we are now with COVID-19 and with the so-called
climate change and so on and the economic disaster that will come from COVID-19, then
we need to know that if you look forward and look over the mountain to the other side that
the Lord has wonderful designs for the earth.
So let's look at October the 24th, 1918.
The soul must invest herself with Jesus, that means you must let Jesus really, really
take over in order to receive him in the sacrament.
So Louisa said, "I was preparing myself to receive my sweet Jesus in the Holy Eucharist
and I prayed that he himself would cover my great misery."
And Jesus told me, "Daughter, in order for the creature to have all the necessary means
to receive me, I wanted to institute this sacrament on the last day of my life.
To be able to line up all my whole life, in other words, all the merits and all the grace
that he had won for us throughout his whole life, he wanted to line it all up in the Eucharist
and make absolutely everything available to us in the Holy Eucharist."
I mean, it's unbelievable, almost, it's fantastic.
So I wanted to be able to line up my whole life around each host as preparation for each
soul that would receive me.
The soul could never receive me if she did not have myself, who is God, preparing it.
Such that, taken only by an excessive love for wanting to give himself to the soul and
she being unable to receive me, the same excessive love led me to give my whole life
in order to prepare her.
So Jesus did all of this to enable you and me to receive the Eucharist.
So it placed my steps, my works, my love before hers.
And since in me there's also my passion, it placed also my pains to prepare her.
So invest yourself with me, really fuse all of me in all of him.
Cover yourself with each one of my acts and come.
So there's a very important preparation for the Holy Eucharist that we need to do.
So afterwards, Jesus added, "My daughter, I look not so much at the suffering but at
the good will of the soul."
Louisa had just lamented that she no longer suffers according to herself and yet she is
continuously in agony over Jesus' privation, she can't see the connection.
So he said, "I don't look so much at the suffering but at the good will of the soul,
at the love with which she suffers because of this the smallest suffering becomes great."
Now this is terribly important for you and me because we're not able for great things
like Louisa was.
The rifles take life within the ore and acquire value.
Now what do you mean by a trifle?
St. Therese of Lesus is famous for many things.
One of them is that she said that even if you pick a pin off the floor with pure love,
it's worth more than all the wonderful things that people are doing, all the plans and all
the projects that they're doing, one little tiny action like that, the difference is the
pure love.
So the trifle is, "I get a headache."
So instead of running for the pan at all, that I run for fusing with Jesus and uniting
that small thing with the pain that he had from his crown of thorns and enter that into
the divine will and let him take the thorns of sin out of people's heads.
Much better than two pan at all.
So trifles take place within the ore.
Other things that St. Therese is famous for is that the little sacrifices she made of just
denying herself in small things, she called them her petals making up a beautiful rose
to offer Jesus at the end of the day.
What a wonderful way to do Lent.
So trifles take life within the ore and acquire value.
And the lack of suffering is stronger than suffering itself.
So Matthew 11, 12, the kingdom of God suffers violence and the valiant take it by force.
What sweet violence it is for me to see a soul who wants to suffer for love of me.
Now, for love of Jesus is the issue and he has been telling us since volume one that
the only motivation that he accepts from us trying to live in the divine will is the motivation
of love.
What do I care if she doesn't suffer when I see that not suffering is for her?
That's Louisa, a nail more piercing than suffering itself.
On the other hand, lack of goodwill, things which are forced and things that are without
love, as great as they may be, they're very small.
I do not look at them, he said, on the contrary, they're a bother, they're a wait.
So very good stuff there to ponder on.
So November 7, 1918, the soul who does the divine will imprison Jesus because we become
a tabernacle and he takes up residence in us.
Finding myself in my usual state, I was saying to my sweet Jesus, if you want me to go out
of the usual state, how is it possible that after so much time you won't make me content?
Jesus said, my daughter, one who does my will and lives in my volition, now we're talking
about the possession of God.
We're not talking about grace back before you entered the divine will arena.
We're not talking about that at all.
So we're talking about a soul actually possessing God in the divine will, it's really wonderful.
He said, one who does my will and lives in my volition, and not for a short time, but
for a period of her life, that means you could start living in the divine will in your 60s
or your 70s, but from then on you're actually living the whole time.
So this is the period of your life.
Sometimes as though a prison for me in her heart, now that prison can be, the other word
is tabernacle, okay, and I want to give you one Corinthians 3, 16.
So she forms as though a prison for me in her heart, and you will see this if you go
to that hour of the passion in which Jesus is in prison, and at the end of it, Louisa
said that when she heard the keys opening the prison, that what came to her were the
keys that opened the tabernacles, okay.
So a person who lives in my will, a period of her life forms as though a prison for me
in her heart, totally and fully of my will.
In other words, it's not material, it's not human.
So as she kept doing my will and tried to live in my volition, because that's all we
can do, she raised the walls of this divine and celestial prison, that is, you make the
tabernacle or the temple for him to live in, and I, to my highest contentment, remained
imprisoned inside of it.
So Jesus is imprisoned in our hearts for us who are living in divine will.
And as she absorbed me, I absorbed her.
This is come union, you are in union with him, but he is in union with you.
That's John 14, verses 20 to 21, you in me and I in you.
So as she absorbed me, I absorbed her into myself.
In such a way as to form in me her prison.
So we live tabernacled in him, okay.
So I also want to give you John 1 14 there, the word became flesh and tabernacled among
us.
Now in the divine will, he tabernacled in us in our hearts and we tabernacled in his
heart as well.
So she has remained imprisoned in me and I in her.
Hence when she, when the soul wants something I say to her, you have always done my will,
it is right that sometimes I do yours.
Now first of all, I want to give you two Corinthians 6 16.
I want to give you Galatians 2 20.
And then I want to remind you of something that Padre Pio said, I deny him nothing and
he denies me nothing.
And I also want to give you that wonderful saying of Saint Augustine of Hippo.
Love God and do what you like because when you're in this union with him, he is in you
and you are in him and he allows you to participate with him in a most wonderful way.
Particularly in the saving of souls, which is a great privilege.
So he says, sometimes you always do my will and sometimes I will do yours, but you see
the two wills are one so that when he does her will, he's doing his own will as well.
And when she's doing his will, she's doing her will because it's his will, it's only
one will.
And he tells us that in the cause of the extraordinary happiness in the most holy trinity is the
simple fact that the three persons of the blessed trinity have won will.
More so he said, since this soul living from my will, what she wants can be the fruit,
the desire of my own will that lives in her.
And therefore, don't worry, when it is necessary, I'll do your will.
Okay, so the two wills are the same.
So we come to November the 15th, 1918, and I just want to remind you that the armistice
day was the 11th of November, 1918 at 11 o'clock in the morning.
So that is the so-called triumph that Jesus was talking about.
So November the 15th, how one can live at the expense of the sanctity of Jesus.
Louisa said, I was thinking, what would be better to think about sanctifying oneself
or to occupy oneself only before Jesus with repairing him and to seek at any cost together
with Jesus, the salvation of souls.
Now that question is a very important question.
It's most likely not coming from herself.
It's most likely a question coming from the priests who are with her.
And it is describing two different levels of sanctity.
Now the first level is the, if you think of three levels of, or three dimensions of living
on this earth, the lowest one is all the unbelievers that are out there in the world.
The middle one is the ordinary sanctity of Christians and you can go right up to the
stage of heroism and being canonized, okay?
And the top level is living in the divine will.
So Louisa is asking, what really is the difference between the middle level and the top level?
So Jesus answered her, my daughter, one who thinks only of repairing me and of saving
souls lives at the expense of my sanctity.
In other words, you don't have to be bothered with your own sanctity and getting to heaven
slowly.
In seeing that the soul wants nothing other than to make reparation, that is to repair
me, and echoing my inflamed heartbeat, she asks me for souls.
And I see in her the characteristics of my own humanity.
So this is the way that Jesus lived on earth only for glorifying his father, obeying his
father, and carrying out the mission to save all souls.
So if we enter into him and are in the divine will and only want to carry out the will of
the father and to save souls and to make reparation through him with him and in him, well that's
the highest, isn't it?
That's God's highest and God's best.
That's the way Jesus lived himself.
So Jesus said, I am taken with folly towards her and I make her live at the expense of
my sanctity, my desires, my love at the expense of my strength, my blood and my wounds.
Now if there's a choice, whether you go with your own expense and your own strength and
your own will and your own wounds or you live at his expense and at the expense of his wounds
and his sanctity and everything, that isn't much of a choice.
There's no way you go for your own stuff if that was available to us.
So he puts it in front of us to enable us to make a decent decision.
I can say he said that I place my sanctity at her disposal.
Just think of that, trying to live in the divine will Jesus makes his own sanctity available
to us when we need to reach out to others and when we need to glorify God, knowing that
she wants nothing other than what I want.
On the other hand, one who thinks about sanctifying only herself lives at the expense of her own
sanctity, whatever that is, and her own strength, which is nothing, and her own love, which
isn't worth talking about, over miserable she will grow, she will feel all the weight
of her misery and she will live in continuous struggle with herself instead.
For one who lives at the expense of my sanctity, her path will flow placid.
Look at that, there's the peace that passes all understanding, Philippians 4, 7.
She will live in peace with herself and with me.
I will watch over her thoughts and each fiber of her heart.
In other words, the Lord is taking care of everything, so that's a Deuteronomy 32, 12,
the Lord alone is her guide.
I will watch over her thoughts and each fiber of her heart and I will be jealous so that
not even one fiber may not ask for souls and that her being may be in continuous pouring
of itself into me in reparation.
Don't you yourself feel this jealousy of mine?
Of course, because this is the way Louisa is living.
So I want to give you Exodus 20, verse 5, and Deuteronomy 5, 9, for the jealousy of the
Lord, for one who truly loves him.
So November the 16th, 1918.
Continuing my usual state, Louisa said, "My sweet Jesus came for just a little and it
seemed that he was feeling a strong pain in his heart.
He asked me for help and he said, 'My daughter, what chains of crimes are happening in these
days?
What a satanic triumph.'
Now he's talking about the triumph of atheistic materialism in 1918.
He's talking about the new Soviet state that was actually set up, the triumph of evil,
that God was literally thrown out and the people who were made to worship the government.
The prosperity of one who is evil is the worst sign, he said.
Now think of the individuals today, this is a century later, who have reached the highest
stage of wealth and influence, and look what they're doing to the earth.
The prosperity of one who is evil is the worst sign.
And it is the means or the way by which faith departs from all nations."
You see, that was the whole idea of the communist thing that you would destroy faith.
And nowadays, a century later, all our nations have just thrown faith out.
It's amazing.
So I want to give you Sam 49 for that, that they will strut and fret their hour upon the
stage and then be heard no more.
That is Shakespeare's quotation of, sorry, not his quotation, his summary of Sam 49.
So they remain as though trapped inside a dark prison because without faith and without grace,
they're in spiritual darkness.
And then the spiritual darkness leads to all kinds of evils.
Instead, humiliation to one who is evil, humiliations to one who is evil are like many
fishers through which light enters.
Again, I want to give you Luke 15 verses 16 to 19.
The humiliation of the prodigal son was what enabled grace and light to enter into him.
And that's why the Lord allows political and social humiliations in order for light to actually
enter.
So humiliations to one who is evil are like many fishers through which light enters such
that making him come back to his senses, you see, that's the prodigal son again.
They bring faith to him.
Now notice, faith was the thing that was eliminated by atheistic materialism and the whole Marxist
thing.
They bring faith to him and to the nations themselves.
So that's faith to the individual and faith to the nation.
So humiliation will do more good to them than any victories or conquests.
So Jesus is thinking in terms of eternal good, not temporary good, not only for the individuals
but for the nations as a whole.
What critical and painful points they will have to go through.
Therefore, there's going to be an awful lot of struggling.
Hell and the wicked are consumed with rage and they begin their plots and their wicked
deeds.
They started the whole one world process very early on and of course they don't want any
believers in this one world government.
They want to make a one world religion that will be so bland it will mean nothing to anybody.
It will simply destroy religion.
So Jesus said poor children, poor church of mine.
We want to give you Psalm 17 verses 8 to 12 and Psalm 36 verses 1 to 4 and Psalm 14 verses
1 to 4.
So November the 29th, 1918, one who goes out of the divine will goes out of the light because
the divine will is light, that's 1 John 1 5 and 2 Timothy 6 16, God lives in unapproachable
light.
So finding myself in my usual state, Louisa said, I was praying that today that Jesus,
as Jesus had promised me another time that when a soul does his will, that sometimes
he consents to do at the will of the soul and he said that on November the 7th on the
second paragraph.
So she said today, you really have to do my will, Louisa doesn't ever let Jesus off
with anything.
If he makes a promise, she makes sure that he hears about it.
My daughter, don't you know that the soul, as the soul goes out of my will, it is like
a day without the sun for her, a day without heat, a day without life, without the life
of the divine attitude within her.
Okay.
So Louisa said, my love, may heaven keep me from doing this, I would rather die than go
out of your will, therefore place your will in me.
This is the thing we need to ask the Lord continuously that he will place his will inside
of us permanently so that it can't go out.
And then say to me, it's my will that today I do yours.
Oh, he said, now you're a cateva, a bad little one.
In other words, she's really come back on him.
All right, I'll make you content.
I will keep you with me as long as I want.
And then I myself will leave you free.
Oh, how content I was, she said, I'm without doing my will, Jesus, identifying his will
with mine while doing his will was doing mine.
Now, I think that's a bit about, that's called going, going around the roundabouts.
She has literally forced him to do her will, and that she's calling it his will.
If you think the Lord can't see through that, even you and I can see through it.
Then afterwards, Jesus spent some time with Louisa, and it seemed that he was dipping
the point of his finger in his most precious blood and would pass it over her forehead,
her eyes, her mouth, and her heart.
And then he kissed her.
And seeing him so affectionate and sweet, she said, I tried to suckle from his mouth
the bitterness, which his heart contained.
Now this is something I've reminded you about before, and that is that Saint Bernard of
Clairvaux warns us in his writings that if you want to kiss Jesus on the lips, then
realize it is Gaul and vinegar that is there.
There's nothing only bitterness there.
That's what was given to him by human beings.
So don't think that it is romantic, that it's going to be pleasant, and that it is for your
pleasure.
It's nothing to do with that, nothing whatsoever.
So when she approached his mouth, she was expecting the bitterness and the Gaul that
was there.
So I tried to suckle from his mouth the bitterness, which his heart contained, and as I used to
do before, but Jesus drew back a little bit and showed me a bundle of other scourges that
were in his hands.
Look, he said, how many other scourges there will be poured upon the earth.
This is why I don't pour into you.
So again, I want to give you Isaiah 55 verses 8 to 9.
So that other reference was right.
Isaiah 55 verses 8 to 9, "My thoughts are not yours, my ways are as different from yours
as the heavens are from the earth."
So Jesus said, "The enemies have prepared all the internal plans to make revolutions."
Now what he's talking about there is that they're setting up this one world government.
They're going to disrupt the whole way that the world will be governed from here on in.
And they're doing it all quietly.
And this was done through the Communists, through the Freemasons, and through the Illuminati,
just to give you three groups.
Now there's nothing left but to finish preparing the external plans, "Am I daughter, how my
heart grieves?
I've no one to pour out my sorrow, and I want to pour it out on you.
You will have patience in hearing me speak very often about sad things, because unfortunately
a time of chastisement is a time of sadness."
I know that you suffer because of it, but it is love that pushes me to do this.
I want to give you Sam 1, 4, 5, verse 17, "God only ever acts out of love."
And chastisement is tough love, but it's still love, and it's given to us, to enable
us, to come round.
I call it an operation without an anesthetic.
Love wants to make its pains known to the beloved.
I almost would not be able to do it without coming to pour myself out on you.
So Louisa said she felt ill in seeing Jesus so embittered.
She could feel his pains in her heart, and Jesus to cheer her gave her a few sips of
the most sweet milk to drink, and then he added, "Now I will withdraw, and I'll leave
you free."
In other words, this is what you wanted, this is what you get, I'm going to stop there
for now.